24-річна Олена сьогодні вперше стане донором крові.
Перед цим дівчина два дні дотримувалася спеціальної дієти.
Воду пила, не їла банани, алкоголь не вживала.
Я думала, що не можна їсти взагалі перед тим, як здавати кров,
але виявилося, треба поснідати, щось солодке, чай.
Раніше якось хотіла до цього долучитися, але не знала, що, куди йти.
Подивилася, що колега ходить, здає, і подумала - треба в неї розпитати.
За порадою, Олена прийшла сюди - у київський Центр служби крові.
Через півгодини фінальних аналізів дівчина - у кріслі донора.
Стиснули, розтиснули, знову підтиснули…
Про хвороби питали, які у мене є хронічні, як себе почуваю.
Тиск міряли, кров з пальця брали.
Ну, сьогодні так людей… Не знаю, чи завжди стільки, але так, немало!
Донори з досвідом, як-от Олексій, кажуть: найбільше людей тут було 24 лютого.
Я спілкувався в черзі. Казали, що приходили вже тричі. Що перші рази не змогли:
постояли, їм сказали, що все, не було можливості так багато прийняти крові.
Всі хочуть якось допомогти.
Просто когось у військкоматі не взяли, хтось не пройшов, хтось не потрапив в ТРО.
Вирішили так допомагати. Країні, військовим, всім…
"ДонорUA" до війни проіснував сім років.
І була зареєстрована кількість донорів - 45 тисяч.
Перших чотири дні війни - з 24 по 28 лютого - в нашій базі плюс 25 тисяч людей нових з’явилося.
Тобто, це таке величезне бажання наблизити нас до перемоги.
Кількість донорів, яких ми відслідковуємо в цифрах, на 60 відсотків виросла. І потреба значно більша.
Керівниця проєкту "ДонорUA", за допомогою якого реєструють охочих здати кров, пояснює:
ще до повномасштабної війни в Україні був сталий дефіцит донорів:
втричі менше за норму, яку рекомендує ВООЗ - 30 донорів на тисячу населення.
А нині в умовах війни, аби вчасно забезпечувати кров’ю та її компонентами тих, хто цього потребує -
і цивільних, і військових, у резерві центрів крові мало би бути два мільйони донорів.
Нині їх 100 тисяч.
Це у нас стенд, де ми виставляємо потреби.
Зараз у нас найбільша потреба в першій позитивній, другій негативній та в четвертій негативній групах крові.
Але все одно ми потребуємо донорів усіх груп крові.
Завідувачка відділення у Центрі служби крові лікарні "Охматдит" розповідає:
багато людей відкладають донорство через хибні уявлення про сам процес.
Це безпечно! Ми використовуємо стерильні матеріали.
І сама донація крові триває всього 5-10 хвилин.
У кожного, мабуть, брали аналізи з вени. Це те саме!
Крім донації крові, ми ще здаємо тромбоконцентрат.
І тут уже довша процедура - середня тривалість близько години.
Ще один з міфів - не можна зранку снідати.
Можна снідати, але просто є багато обмежень:
рідка каша, але без масла, без молока, відварена риба, можна солодкий чай з нежирним печивом.
Стати донорами можуть не всі, є протипоказання:
хронічні інфекційні, паразитарні, психічні захворювання, хвороби крові, серця та онкологія.
Після перенесених операцій, переливання крові та татуювань здавати кров не можна протягом року.
У мене була заборона, бо було хірургічне втручання.
Сьогодні усі, кого допустили до процедури, можуть стати донорами двома способами.
Перший - здати компоненти крові - тромбоцити, які допомагають людям з їхнею нестачею,
зокрема при захворюваннях крові.
Другий метод - здати цільну кров, яку потім також розділяють на складники - плазму та еритроцити.
Вони життєво необхідні пацієнтам з крововтратами.
Після забору цільної крові вона ще проходить через фільтр.
Пакет лейкофільтрованої крові стає на завантаження на центрифугування на розділення.
На холодильниках 4 градуси. Тут постійно контролюється ця температура.
Без кріоконсервування, тобто заморозки на 2 або 3 роки,
"свіжі" еритроцити можуть зберігатися до 42 діб, тромбоцити - до п'яти діб, плазма - до трьох.
До лікарень кров частіше доставляють за конкретної потреби із запасу,
а до лінії фронту в умовах війни - возять у спеціальних холодильних камерах двічі на тиждень,
аби завжди був резерв.
"ДонорUA" в тому числі транспортує кров з усієї України в прифронтові лікарні.
Ми повністю закриваємо північно-східні і південний фронт, де відбуваються бойові дії.
Навіть якщо ви проживаєте у Львові, на Закарпатті чи в інших містах, де, здавалося б, немає активних бойових дій,
ви все одно йдіть здавайте кров, тому що ви станете точно тією частинкою життя, яка поїде до прифронтових лікарень.
Ніхто з донорів не знає, кому дістанеться їхня кров - хочуть допомогти будь-кому, хто цього потребує.
Будь-кому, кому потрібна допомога - моя кров.
Кожна людина повинна знайти в собі мотивацію, чому вона хоче це зробити.